we sound like your phone i I just put
myself in airplane mode man oh I told
you that that 20 minutes ago you put
your phone in airplane mode too
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be fine
without me
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the minimus
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn I am
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists yes we seem like Voltron
forming music there as long as it's
performed by LL Cool J I approve he's
the only person who's given us rights
just that well you know last year yes
Peter Doran that's what I just said it's
what I just corrected myself with well
we are freestyling today folks we don't
have a script in front of us we don't
have any pieces of paper but we're this
we'll be posting on two days after the
new year it's a brand new year 2017
we're recording this today on the day
our documentary minimalism a documentary
about the important things comes out on
Netflix so we're actually getting ready
to record a Facebook live session which
you'll be able to go back I guess and
watch that you won't be able to join
live unless you already know about it
from our last episode on creating we
talked about that but today we're
talking about sort of new beginnings or
new year but but really back to basics
for is the theme for us this year Ryan I
don't know what you've been up to lately
but I just got back from beautiful Los
Angeles California and and did you get
frozen uh well I was i I was just so
looking forward to coming back to
Missoula man I didn't think I would be
I'm just meeting like really I got
frozen early like two feet of snow out
there I know right it's it's supposed to
be negative 19 degrees tonight
negative 19 was the wind no no no is
that with the humidity or yeah but it's
a dry
in Celsius it's probably pretty close in
Celsius actually I know that's before
windchill but not wasn't in Los Angeles
for a long weekend Bex and I had a free
weekend so we went out there and man I
had one of the best times I've had in in
years it was amazing we saw Johnny Lang
in concert and what was he playing it
man no it was it was a big venue but we
had we had really good seats
and oh my goodness he I didn't I'd never
seen John Lang I loved his music but
I've never seen him live before and yeah
he's probably the the best blues player
I've ever seen but not just that
are you into Blues now what it's weird
that like six it'll be jazz some white
guy from Fargo North Dakota is the best
player that I've ever seen he's awesome
and I I've never never seen him alive
before but my goodness I mean the
intensity of his performance I've it's
definitely the best concert I've seen in
my 30s it was unbelievable and yeah I
wouldn't got frozen and that really
helped my back a lot so cryotherapy for
the longtime listeners you know what
what I'm talking about
we don't have cryotherapy here and was
over yeah yeah but but yeah I wouldn't
got froze I went to the Russian
bathhouse I I oh man we went to go see
Anthony Jeselnik and do comedy no way it
was so good man at the Comedy Store
Marc Maron was there too just really
yeah on a whim like and a bunch of other
just hilarious comics and I just curious
if people like get up and walk out on
Anthony Jeselnik know I think they knew
that they're getting into I mean he he
was pretty offensive but it blatantly so
intentionally so like you could tell
he's basically trolling you at some
point like he's trying to get people
upset yeah and it was hilarious though
it's over the openers the openers were
just hilarious and then we went and
walked around Grove Park there isn't the
old Los Angeles Zoo is in Griffith Park
it's abandoned I don't know how long
it's been abandoned I find a guess I'd
say 20 years or so
and it's very post-apocalyptic but
gorgeous I don't know if you ever
watching those videos on like YouTube or
anywhere is this it's in Griffith Park
Griffith partners yeah which is you know
where the Hollywood sign is okay yeah
yeah it's I mean Griffith Park is like
this massive massive park the
observatories there it's right in the
middle of LA as weird though because
you're in the middle of Los Angeles one
of the most populous cities in in the
country but you're in the middle of
nature as well because you're in this
huge expansive Park and there's this
abandoned Zoo there and it was people
who animals just got up and left yeah
yeah I think they were on strike and
just never came back I don't know how
that works people who live in LA are
probably appalled right now like you
idiot it's it's actually not you know I
mean I'm sure I'm getting some of the
details wrong but it was it was really
amazing and so it was a great trip and
then I came back here and like my car
was in the parking lot at the at the
airport and my goodness like two feet of
snow and uber now why would you drive to
the airport because I didn't want to
trust over in Missoula Montana at 4:00
a.m. when I was going out there that's
not a safe bet I always order like a
half-hour ahead of time I got those
early flights when I have those early
flight so that's every flight out of
Missoula man yeah I mean they leave at
5:30 a.m. or 6:30 a.m. haha yeah well so
so let's talk about where we're gonna
look ahead but first we're gonna glance
in the rearview a little bit so
yesterday we're recording this on
December 15th like I said the day our
documentary hits Netflix if it's not out
in your country by the way I know a lot
of people are frustrated it's not in
Denmark or Brazil or wherever I'm sorry
Netflix didn't pick it up everywhere but
don't worry it's still available
worldwide on Vimeo so if you want a
chance to watch the film and by the way
there's six hours of exclusive bonus
content on Vimeo you can't get anywhere
else so a bunch of extra interviews and
stuff on Vimeo so you can find it there
you can also rent it on iTunes and
on in google play now and so it's
available on Netflix it's available to
rent it's available on DVD it's
available wherever you want check out
the documentary if you're interested and
sorry if it's not available in your
country on your preferred platform but
it is there on Vimeo if you're if you're
willing to go check it out over there
you know we could do for those countries
what's that we could convert the
documentary into a play and put it on
that periscope no and then we will tour
internationally Oh
with many minimalism a documentary by
the important things play minimalism a
musical about the important things is an
idea so we just turned six years old
congratulations
you know me mentally and emotionally we
are six years old Phase II spent six
years man yes so so December 14th 2010
was the official launch date of the
minimalists calm now we started writing
about a month or two actually you were
journaling back in August September of
2010 but the official launch date of the
website and it started as this project
almost like an online book in a way or
an online journal a weblog of sorts wait
a minute
patent pending and and so it started
with Ryan's 21 day journey into
minimalism and I wrote some stuff and I
was really hoping to transition into a
fictive writing career I won the right
literary fiction full-time but then I
started finding immense value in this
medium to communicate in non-fiction
writing whether that was books you know
or blogging or even social media I would
argue we're not very good at social
media the two of us maybe that's a good
thing but but thankfully we have Jess
who helps us out with a lot of social
media stuff I just want to say speak for
yourself I was on Instagram like five
days ago today you asked me what
Instagram stories was no I asked you
what insta story was
then I actually which what Instagram
story was I actually what insta story
was it I was being facetious to be fair
to be fair you use snapchat I think
occasionally yeah like I can't you know
it's funny cuz like snapchat I guess I
could felt like I could be snapchatting
this um I could be finding those little
moments during the day but like it feels
really fake to me to like do that
I feel stressful to me doesn't feel fake
it feels well I feel stressful and fake
when I'm forcing myself to like create
these cool snaps or something welcome
back up ginger in my kitchen right oh
wow look at this cool angle of my head
but no I mean and then no offense anyone
out there who uses snapchat Gazette or
no offense anyone who wears hats of
course no no and I actually will get on
and look at people's stories so don't
stop snapchatting because I do like to
be the warrior don't get me wrong but
when I use snapchat it is typically like
if I'm on vacation or like up or like
I'm going to Florida we're going to
Florida next week we are yeah so back to
Florida that snow and stuff there were
the grandparents and my grandma's a
little funny dog I swear to God they
dressed them up in like a little leather
jacket and like the little leather biker
hat it's hilarious I can only imagine
what they're gonna do for Christmas with
them so when you say don't snap stop
snap chatting is that a journey song no
no okay
well so anyway I think the point of that
was we're not good at social media it
was my commentary oh we're not bad at it
we but it's not our preferred creative
medium let's let's just say that there
are some people who use social media as
their exclusive creative medium in fact
I've seen some real artists who have
used platforms like vine which is gone
by the wayside or is going by the
wayside now they're they're shutting
down vine oh my goodness I know oh you
saved the emo vine yeah yeah so my
favorite vine was of Ryan being emo Ryan
anyway so that I've what I've learned
over the last six years is that I've
become a lot more vehicle agnostic we've
done these different projects over the
years so in 2010 we
started the blog in which we called a
website at the time we didn't really
know what a blog was and and in 2011 we
started writing a book called minimalism
minimalism of a meaningful life
the initial title was minimalism in 21
days and that was Ryan's 21-day journey
that which is all up on the website for
free
we had a 300 page book about minimalism
and were like wait a minute this
shouldn't be our debut effort to the
world and so we basically scrapped it
and started with a blank page and in a
month or so I wrote a new draft of
minimalism of meaningful life but it was
really out of the stories and everything
that we had had we were uncovering these
values in our in our life and starting
to live a different way and by living
that different way it gave us something
to write about and I think that's the
reason I wrote fiction for such a long
time is I wasn't really I wasn't very
proud of the life I was living I was all
stints ibly successful in the corporate
world you you and I as we were climbing
the corporate ladder but there was
nothing particularly interesting about
being the director of operations for 150
retail stores I was really I was a
mozart of spreadsheet development but
there's nothing that's too interesting
about Microsoft Excel in fact that seems
to be the opposite of interesting to me
I cringe when I see a spreadsheet now
and I was really good at spreadsheet
there were many people at our
corporation who were very impressed with
your title in your job but yeah no I
know but but not interested in yeah and
and we talked about this and a couple
episodes ago with our our episode titled
creating and how I really I wasn't I
wasn't crude I didn't feel like I was
doing something meaningful or Purpose
Driven or even creative and that was a
big problem in my life and so right I
wanted to read you something I I don't
usually respond to people on Instagram
but since today our our documentary came
out on Netflix I was just taking a look
at some of some of the comments on our
posting we got a really interesting
question that had nothing to do with the
film
and I wanted to at least read that to
you we had a lot of random we do get a
lot of random questions yeah let me see
if I can find a Shawn in the meantime
since Ryan and I are going back I was
just in California we're going to
Florida next week maybe you can find
some LL Cool J back to Cali and insert
that right now we can only insert it
once in this pod not not the Biggie
version the LL Cool J version please
that was like the only tape I had in the
80s that was a hip-hop tape was because
his album turned 30 years old last year
and so I had like Def Leppard and LL
Cool J on cassette dude my dad would
never let me own an LL Cool J or a Def
Leppard cent tape album or a Def Leppard
album so this this was a a comment from
Katy or a question really she said hello
the minimalists I've been at my current
job for a few years now I sincerely
enjoy it the company treats me well and
I've got a career path in a place that
I'm excited to follow no complaints
except one 2016 has been a year of
awakening for me I've been a vegetarian
a vegetarian now for almost 11 months
and I am on quote the journey to
becoming the best most authentic version
of myself however my values no longer
align with the company I work for the
company I work for is the largest
protein producer in the world meat
that's just one sentence it just has
meat what am I to do I struggle with the
environmental impacts this company makes
but the job itself brings me joy
SOS now let me tell you what my response
was and I like to talk about it so I
just responded and I said if your short
term actions don't align with your long
term values you will eventually
experience discontent in fact it sounds
like you are already experiencing the
initial twinge ergo you have only two
options change your actions or change
your values option three experienced
prolonged discontent mmm it's good man
no that's exactly that's exactly what I
was thinking
like someone like a lot of mentoring
clients that I get there at this boiling
point uh-huh and they want to like leave
their job right away uh-huh and that is
like well it's probably the worst thing
to do like if you haven't made any plans
and you've just allowed yourself to get
to this boiling point and then you want
to leave like leaving your job I mean
that's that's it might make you feel
temporarily better but then it's great
longer discontent right if you don't
have a plan then it's gonna create yeah
exactly longer discontent so it sounds
like she's starting to boil yes she's
not at the boiling point not yet it's
it's gonna count if she doesn't start
planning now yeah then there will be a
point where she chief is gonna feel
trapped essentially and so over the last
six years you and I have done a lot of
different things we've caught a lot of
things on we started blogging we wrote
that first book in 2012 we moved from
Dayton Ohio our hometown out to Montana
and started writing the first draft of
everything that remains which is still
my favorite thing that we've ever
created our memoir and in 2013 we
started a publishing company called
asymmetrical Press
it's a indie publishing house I was a
publishing house for the indie at heart
is is the tagline there and we moved
into a house with Colin Wright our
business partner and and started that it
was really a publishing company to put
to publish our own stuff because I was
tired of I no longer wanted to go the
traditional route I've seen the faults
of going the traditional route and the
gatekeepers and waiting for someone else
permission and we learned from
publishing our first book minimalism
that you can do this on your own there's
a difference between a garage band and a
really good indie band the same thing
there's there's a difference between
self-publishing and really good
independent publishing and and so we
decided we're gonna start this this
publishing company and then we we've
decided to help some other authors along
the way other people we actually
whenever we help someone we say we want
to help you fail better because that's
really over what we're doing if
someone's book is a wild success that
asymmetrical press
ishes it's because of them it's not
because of me and Ryan and Colin did
something amazing we give them a little
push occasionally but generally the
books that we publish the rice metro
press they aren't huge bestsellers it
helps someone get their their work out
into the world but the idea of creating
that publishing company well so we
wouldn't just have another publishing
company we didn't want to when Colin
came to us with this idea first I said
that sounds interesting but it sounds
like you're just you just want to create
another publishing house just like
everyone else like Random House or
penguin or or whomever HarperCollins and
and that's fine that those exist I'm not
I'm not against traditional publishing I
just don't think it's I don't think it's
the only route for people and so I said
how could we create a publishing company
they said yes to everyone
things like what are you talking about
how it's not even possible what do you
mean we create a publishing house that
says yes to everyone so because I don't
want to read everyone's manuscript and I
don't want publishing to be my full-time
job I I want to be able to publish our
own books and then share that recipe
with other people and so the way we
decided to say yes to everyone was to
create a template the exactly here's the
exact process for how asymmetrical press
publishes the minimalist books and also
Colin writes books by the way Colin is
32 years old he's published 35 books
everything from fiction to short stories
to self-help books to memoirs and
everything in between very prolific
writer and so he's learned a lot of
lessons going through that process over
and over and over and then Ryan and I
have learned a lot of lessons especially
about not just the writing process but
getting a book out into the world in
front of a large group of people and so
what we did is we put up a whole recipe
at a symmetrical website and Sean if you
could put that in the show notes that'd
be great it is basically a how-to guide
how to publish an independent book it's
a soup to nuts approach from A to Z or
from writing the book which by the way
is the most difficult step actually
writing the thing but once you've done
it there's still like five steps after
that there's a whole editing process
there's yeah formatting process there is
promotional process there are all of
these processes that you have to go
through to get a book out into the world
and even once the book is out in the
world
it's all about the longtail it's not
about like well however my first week
sales looking and they said about that
anymore it's about getting this creation
in front of people that they're gonna
find value it and when people find value
in it they share it it's funny you bring
up the first week sales yes it's like
typically most authors I know with us
and a lot of other people they
experienced the most sales like a year
to two years later after they write the
book and publish it you're absolutely
right in fact the so that first book we
wrote minimalism love a meaningful life
its best sales month was month number
twenty five so it was it was over two
years after yeah and even now those book
all three of our books tend to do better
now than they did early on when they
first came out just because we have a
larger audience now we reach more people
via different platforms and so whether
it's it's our sa collection which is
called essential and by the way these
are all available an audiobook now too
so it's an entirely new format that you
can get your words in front of people
and audio is just becoming more and more
popular with audible and then of course
with podcasts so more people are
listening to audiobooks as well and so
it's another way to get your creation in
front of the world another step but
you're absolutely right Ryan it's not
about how are my first week sales my
gonna make the New York Times bestseller
list no probably not and that's okay I
don't know if I've talked about this
excuse me in the last episode but I had
a a rather well-known New York Times
bestselling author who was like we did a
podcast episode and he he before
beforehand he asked me hey so are you
making back your advance on the book yet
and this guy has been in New York Times
bestseller list and I'm like what are
you talking about make back our advance
like we do this ourselves like I earn a
living a full-time living as an author
and I it feels great to be able to say
that we're not making millions of
dollars off of our books but we don't
have to
we're minimalist that helps out a lot
but it also helps that that we continue
to find ways to get that material in
front of people because they tend to
share it but no I it's not about having
an advance that we make we make somewhat
of a living off of our books you know
every month and that's really nice
but I don't have to wait for someone
else permission I don't have to wait for
someone's advance if you want to go that
route that's okay there's nothing
inherently wrong with that but realize
that it's not the the only route anymore
and so we we started the publishing
company so we could show other people
hey that's not the only route there are
many paths to get to what your
definition of success is first you have
to figure out what a success look like
for you and I think that's important and
then after starting that publishing
company and finishing writing our book
everything that remains
Ryan you and I hit the road for a year
so talk about getting working hard to
get a book in front of people we went to
a hundred cities did a hundred and
nineteen events in eight countries we
donated basically a year of our life to
get this message in front of people all
the events were free seventy-five
thousand people attended these events
and if you've seen our documentary which
covers a lot of that it started all
fairly small you know a lot of the
events only a few people would show up
but as the word spread and more and more
people found value in it more people
showed up and then eventually spoiler
alert you there were hundreds or in the
case of Australia thousands of people
who were showing up at book signing
event so there are major New York Times
bestselling authors who can't can't get
60 people to show up at an event and
there are people like us who do it on
our own
and the question is doing on your own
doesn't doesn't doesn't abdicate your
you from your responsibility to still
put your best work forward in fact I
think it ups the ante it it makes you
because you're not beholden to anyone
other than your audience so it's no
longer about publishers and editors and
other people were saying yes to you you
want an audience to say yes to you and
the only way to do that is to be able to
look yourself in the mirror and say this
is the absolute best I could do given
the resources I have and so Ryan you and
I took that book that was well the first
step was getting the book done and out
there into the world but once it did
wasn't it wasn't like well what's our
first week sales look like no was like
alright now let's hit the road and go
100 cities and drive around Orion's 2004
Toyota Corolla and with boxes of books
in the trunk and go from bookstore to
belittle is lighting kit yeah yeah well
yeah Matt was with us and he had he had
his huge lighting kit that took up half
the backseat and and going from city to
city sometimes sleeping at rest stops or
you know the occasional hampton inn or
on readers couches or Airbnb and and
found ways to to get that message in
front of more and more people and it was
an amazing experience I wouldn't trade
it for anything and then we came back
and I'll tell you man I don't know how
much you experience this but December of
2014 I felt I felt depressed I don't
really know how else to say it man but I
we were on the road for 11 months for
the most part and we we come back and it
was just like I was used to that go go
go go go we're on the road we're getting
we're meeting with people we're changing
lives like it feels great and then all
of a sudden it comes to a screeching
halt and yeah it was nuts man I remember
yeah just like a month because we came
back from Australia on that last yeah so
we were in UK and so England Scotland
Wales Northern Ireland and then Ireland
so I feel like when we went so like we
got to Australia what was that like
beginning of November a second week in
November that was the beginning November
we were there for three weeks and I feel
like when we left is when I just started
to like kind of adjust to the to the
sleeping in the jetlag and stuff yeah in
Australia that was brutal yeah it really
was
so then when I came back to the States
oh by the way member I had food
poisoning like 3:00 on the last stop
yeah City number 103 days before we
headed back to the US yeah one day right
before that last stop I got food it was
a double header that night yeah Perth
Australia 800 people show up to this
gallery but and yeah you are you you
give a double talk to talks one night
with food poisoning that's man and then
we're flying back and with our layover I
remember it being something absurd like
54 hours to get back to Missoula from
Perth there was something nuts me I
remember that month it took me all of
December to just get back into the sleep
cycle man to not feel like I was like
floating in space I just remember having
like a spacey like really worn out
feeling that whole month yeah you know
and not just adjusting to the time zones
but yeah going from oh my god like yeah
we've got to get up go to some
interviews then we maybe can grab some
good coffee then maybe go to a museum
and then we have an event and then we
get up the next morning maybe do a
couple more interviews and then off to
the next city it was like this constant
like you said go go go go yeah yeah and
and I mean these weren't these weren't
your the the big fun sexy interviews
that you would think it's not all work
we did we did the Today Show and that
was all in school but we're also going
to the showing up at the Morning News
remember the cable access place we went
to in what was that in Florida it was
actually a really good interview but it
was like literally it was this this guy
who like showed up like five minutes
before we were supposed to go on yeah
and there was one gentleman there who
was the producer the director the
cameraman the sound man the editor leg
it was literally a two-person operation
it actually came together pretty well
but it was like you know that you know
cable-access feel first it was very
between two ferns the aesthetic was
between two ferns yeah but you're right
it was still you know and I'll tell you
what man like doing hundreds of
interviews and let's come remind me to
come back to interviews before this is
all over doing literally hundreds of
interviews in 2014 whether it's radio TV
newspaper all that stuff man
there were some days we do seven to nine
interviews in a day
and I'll tell you really it gave me the
confidence that I needed to be able to I
mean I don't think we could do this
podcast if we hadn't gone through that
whole thing
it gave me the confidence to just talk
into a microphone or talk to people and
talk about our message in a way that
that I hadn't talked about I had written
about it but that's completely different
from talking extemporaneously about
minimalism or our journey or simple
living or whatever and so it really
helped out and then doing those 119
events throughout the year in front of
crowds that that helped out as well
because yeah there are basically three
things that I hate I hate traveling I
hate public speaking and I hate large
crowds of people and what I'm gonna do
that for an entire year non-stop well
it's not that I actually hate those
things it's a make me uncomfortable
right the crowds of people maybe I'm an
introvert speaking in front of a crowd
it's the number one fear it's it's
number one over death even people are
more afraid of public speaking than they
are of death and and then of course
traveling like I'm not a huge fan of
just perpetually traveling and unpacking
and repacking bags and and and going
through all of that but that that said
it was still an amazing experience but
then we came back here and it was just
slamming on the brakes and I had to like
readjust to like okay I'm not dishing
out a thousand hugs this week I need to
find a new way to make sure I feel
significant I feel certain I feel cared
about and did you win yourself off like
just going around hug and random people
yeah yeah it was I almost got shot in
Montana that's all why we always
announce it by the way folks always say
I'm a hugger because 62 percent of the
population here has a gun anyway yes so
2015 once I got back into the groove of
things we just saw okay well what's
another thing we can do and so Ryan and
I did this year of contribution and we
did a bunch of stuff we built three
water wells and Malawi with the folks
from charity water and with the folks in
our audience for many of you who donated
money
to that we were able to build wells for
I think it was twelve hundred and fifty
people in Malawi and and that was really
amazing and then we we built it we
helped build an orphanage in Honduras
with Joshua Becker and the folks from
his charity the hope effect and we with
the folks at misfit and enjoy coffee
house over and Laos we built an
elementary school over there and with
your help as well the people who donated
to that and so we were able to help out
with that we also had some extra money
from that so we funded a high school for
a year in Kenya and of course we've done
a bunch of other philanthropic things as
well
we wanted to find different ways to
contribute to the world around us and
we'll continue to contribute we wanted
to dedicate a year to the contribution
as we were finishing up the the
documentary which by the way so we just
turned six years old we've spent the
last three years in this documentary
we've spent half of the minimalists
comms life span on this this documentary
so think about that we perspective men
we filmed the first few frames of that
documentary in December of 2013 and that
was that was three years ago this month
basically and and it took three years to
get that out in the world and so this
year 2016 we really once that the
documentary was finished we worked hard
to get out into the world so we did a
theatrical release and the film showed
an about 400 theaters across the United
States and Canada and Australia and
limited release and a few other
countries throughout throughout the
world and then we put it up online on
Vimeo and iTunes and Google Play and all
those places we also did a tour a
theater tour this year back back in May
and June United States and Canada about
15 different cities bringing the message
to in front of in front of more people
right and and now it's available on
Netflix and it's like finally I
breathing out the sigh of relief like
like it's finally out there in the world
and I feel like today the day comes out
on Netflix is is like the last thing
getting it out there in front of the
world because that's such an important
part and people don't realize like if
this creation is meaningful and I feel
proud about it and I've gotten so many
messages about it's changed people's
lives and I feel so fortunate to be able
to do that so I want to be able to get
it out in front of more people do I
think it's for everyone no I think it's
for people who are fed up with with the
status quo and they're looking for
something different they're looking for
a new recipe or at least some new
ingredients for their recipe and with
the documentary we really wanted to go
out there and show you know what
minimalism is not this this crazy
radical lifestyle it can be if you want
it to be there are some people in there
who live in tiny houses or or the Colin
Wright who travels to new country over
four months and that's great for him
yeah I would posit too that that's not
too radical for those guys though maybe
to you or I would be radical but right
exactly it's it's it's it's radical
compared to the average but the problem
with average is average is debt average
is stress average is overwhelmed average
is discontent average is working a
nine-to-five for 40 years for seven
different corporations who don't love or
care about you just because they're
there nebulous entities right and that's
average and so I wanted to be not
average but I also didn't want it to be
radical I wanted to show there are
practical sides of minimalism so whether
it's Leo Bob Alta and his his six kids
and his wife Eva and Joshua Becker
living in the suburbs with his wife Kim
and their two kids and Tammy Strobel or
whoever it may be
Cortney Carver there are a bunch of
different people who were living
different lifestyles all under the guise
all under this banner of minimalism and
so it's not just about the Josh and Ryan
show and even our lives are appreciably
different over the last six years we've
both fallen in love as it were
you met Mariah at a really interesting
time it was before we went on on tour
yeah before that the big tour yeah back
in 2014 so that was 2013
r-13 oh yeah that's right October 2013
so so you were on the road the whole
time when you first started dating yeah
you're on the road a bunch yeah didn't
really know where I was gonna go but by
January I was like god this is really
cool cool girl like I would really would
like to stay in contact and we did i
strengthened your relationship with her
because you were away and allowed you to
be communicative in a way that you may
have not been had you just been in close
proximity mmm I don't know if it
strengthened the relationship as much as
like secured the relationship okay
meaning that you know we had lots of
talks leading up to it like whether we
were gonna you know continue to date or
whatever and I'm like you know I will
totally keep in contact with you and
maybe you come out to a few cities
during that year so forth and so on yeah
it was a lot of stress so you know I
don't want to say it was it strengthened
it because I think if I did that again
like she'd have to come with me uh-huh I
gotta get leave her again for you know
ten months or eleven months whatever it
was right but yeah I just misspoke I say
strengthen I mean you got to know her in
a different way that you maybe wouldn't
have gotten to know her otherwise I I
know this about Bex because I was on a
short tour tour when we first met and we
just exchanged emails and and I got to
know her she's a really good writer
which is was very appealing to me and so
we exchanged it was sort of like being
pen pals via email and and that was
really cool but it started I was a
friendship in fact I've set that
expectation and she asked about wanting
to take it any farther and I said no III
I want I want to start this out as a
friendship and build a really good
foundation and that's something if
something comes out of that and we can
build on it as an intimate relationship
that's great if not then we have a
really great friendship and that's great
too and it's a win-win situation let's
set it up that way it requires some
patience and and delayed gratification
so to speak and it really strengthened
the communication between us and that's
why I asked I didn't I mean you were on
the road much much longer and so uh
last year we did do a short word tasting
tour back in 2015 and we brought like a
5 authors on the road with us and a
musician and went to 35 different cities
along the Mountain States in the western
states of the United States and Canada
and that was a blast
like we put a van full of smelly guys I
miss all those smelly guys because all
of the the responsible female authors
that we have on asymmetrical like they
couldn't you know leave their families
and stuff the other families assume on
whatever and so we got the we got Colin
and Sean mihalick who had just had a
book come out that it was really great
that we got a sky steal he was a very
talented musician he would hit the road
with us and we just went to a bunch of
cities a lot of them we hadn't been to
before like Provo that was that was
really cool yeah yeah it was Josh Wagner
was there anyone else Josh Wagner was
there he had a great book who had come
out and we had some guests and in
different cities but it was it was a
really fun short tour I mean two months
and learned a lot of lessons from that
as well as strengthened our relationship
with a lot of independent bookstores too
and we always encourage people to
support their local and eBooks bookshop
in fact in 2014 we did that tour we went
out of our way to support local indie
book shops except in some cities big
cities like Dallas or Las Vegas or
Regina Saskatchewan massive metropolis
that we went to there are a lot of
cities like that they had no independent
bookstores at all so enforce hopefully
that's changing because I know the tide
is changing there are more print books
being sold relative to ebooks this year
than last year I'm not necessarily
advocating one of the over one over the
other
I prefer ebooks personally but I know a
lot of people enjoy that print book
experience and so you have you have the
option of both which which I really like
and so yes we did that tour last year
and we ryan and i actually gave up 100%
of the profits from that to to some
charities and also we helped out some of
the authors who went on the road and
said hey man you gave up to two years of
your life take a little bit of extra
money from this and so again another
another part of our year
of contribution and then this year we
got that we finally got the document or
out there
it's a sigh of relief I feel like it's
done and now we're looking ahead to 2017
and if you know us you know Ryan and I
we'd like to focus on on one thing a
year sometimes two but we tend to focus
on on one major project and we that
means but to say no to everything else
so we could say yes to everything that
serves that that particular project and
so for 2017 the theme is getting back to
basics and there are a few reasons for
this but let's talk about what we mean
by getting back to basics well when we
started the website six years ago what
was the basic it was it was writing on
the website it was so let's just say
writing in general that that's our our
main craft but let's go beyond that what
what is writing writing is communicating
an expression right communication and
expression and what are other ways that
you and I communicate and express
ourselves well this this platform we're
talking in this microphone right now
that is another way that you and I have
found value and found growth immense
growth this year if you go back and
listen to our you're almost 50 episodes
ago now we do an appreciable a better
job just talking into a microphone than
we did on episode you know five or
whatever right practice makes perfect
yeah yeah or much better at least
imagine when it'll be 50 episodes from
now or 50 years from now oh my god you
know I think that this is another medium
for us to communicate and express so
let's just talk about what is
back-to-basics mean it means creating I
mean for us it's gonna be writing and
podcasting so throughout 2017 it's
really about how do we get back to
writing more for the website and also
maybe maybe some books or something else
that we're working on we're also working
on what I'll just call it a secret
project right now although we've had to
postpone some stuff and I'd like to talk
about that and talk about why but
writing is is something that's really
important to me and it's something I'm
really passionate about and I've had
four false starts in the last three
years
for books that I've tried to start
writing and they just haven't gone
anywhere for me and and so it's been
interesting because I know I'll get an
itch for an idea and I'll start working
on it and then it doesn't go anywhere
but I don't have the time or capacity to
focus on that thing and so for 2017 I
want to focus more on writing it's the
thing that I'm really passionate about
but I also want to focus on growth and
that that's going to be through this
through this medium through podcasting
and so that's how we're gonna create
with the world we're gonna get back to
basics we're gonna write more I don't
know whether or not a book will come out
of this I know Ryan and I are working on
some new live material as well and that
is that the sort of third leg of the the
Triad here of the the tripod of
communication for us and expression is
Ryan and I have a guy on a bunch of
Tours now our first tour was started in
2011 and we were lucky to get two to
eight people to show up at our tour
stops and that was great because it
allowed us to shape a lot of the content
for everything that remains I gotta tell
you when two people show up uh-huh
all the pressure I have just goes away
there's no pressure so so our our plan
in 2017 is to hit the road with six
ideas and bring them into some small
crowds some tiny crowds of people where
it's gonna be a hundred people or so so
not that the massive five six seven
hundred seat theaters but small spaces
intimate spaces where we're working on
these six new ideas and we're writing
them in ideally if the writing goes well
we want to bring them on the road in
front of people and sort of test them
out the same way a a comedian you know
if you see if I see Anthony Jeselnik
he's gonna do the same set over and over
and over before he requires his next
Netflix special whatever because it
allows him to work out that material in
front of a crowd see what's funny see
the timing and we want to do the same
thing in front of crowds as long as the
the writing goes well but we also have
had to say no to some other things
recently
and many of you have known about my I've
had some health issues this year and it
really started 2015 and one could argue
it started even well before that so in
my late 20s I went on a a large round of
antibiotics I stayed on a supposedly a
benign amount of antibiotics in my in my
late 20s and I was on antibiotics for
several years and it completely
destroyed my gut microbiome I mean
completely leveled it and the reason I
was on those antibiotics was for I had
this crazy scalp acne I mean it was just
awful and it was and my dermatologist so
hey here just take these magic pills and
it will clear it up well the reason I
had that scalp back acne was actually
I'm allergic to soy mm-hmm and anytime I
and even now like if there's
accidentally soy in something I can all
no the next day because I have just a
terrible reaction to it right and and so
I was on antibiotics for a long time
completely killed my my gut microbiome
and it's caused all these other
sensitivities in my life around that
same time we were also remodeling a
bunch of retail stores for the the
corporation that we worked for and so I
was exposed to a lot of chemicals in a
very high-stress environment and I was
killing my gut microbiome at the same
time and so I as a result have developed
what's called multiple chemical
sensitivities and I've heard from a lot
of people in our audience when I've
mentioned this just in passing I don't
have any answers for you yeah so the
reason I don't I don't talk a whole lot
about the health problems I'm going
through is I am working very diligently
to correct my health problems and it's
probably gonna take 18 months or so to
get back to where I'd like to be but I'm
working very diligently every single day
on on this arduous process of healing
and in this process I don't have any I
don't have all the answers yet I have
what could potentially be answers and I
know a lot of people are out there
suffering with multiple chemical
sensitivities something like 16 to 18
percent of people in the United States
have a version of multiple chemical
sensitivities now mine are going to be a
lot worse than some people with some
or really bad I mean you've seen these
these documentaries where people can't
even live in a house anymore I have to
go live in a tent out in the wilderness
the gala was butchered in the lamb with
yeah
couple weeks ago when we walked in there
Marla Sarris was with us and I went to
give her a hug and like I went to grab
hug she's like all night you know nice
nice to meet you
and I guess she didn't ask me because
I'm a guy but then she went to hug Marla
and she was like wait do you smell and
she was like what if you she was like
yeah do you wear any fragrances or
anything she's like no I don't she's
like okay good because I can't stand
like she has the same thing where she
will leave the room like just if she's
in a setting where all of a sudden
someone comes in with some like strong
fingers fragrances she will have such a
bad reaction that she literally just
like get up and walk out like she's left
in the middle of meals like really
things that seem rude but at the end of
the day it's like she necessary yeah she
can't stand to be in a room not yet for
any other reason that her body doesn't
react to it well yeah yeah so I I'll
tell you I don't react to it and so I'll
go through some details here because
hopefully I don't like sharing you know
my own personal struggles as I'm going
through them I like to share them
generally in the rearview because I
think it can help people and serve the
greater good but to give you an idea of
how how we got to where I am
I started experience I've had back
problems for about the last 20 years I
have a broken l5 vertebrae and it's
gotten really bad and being on that tour
in 2014 it really messed up my thought
you had like an appendicitis or
something like I was having I thought I
had a hernia because I was having this
weird this weird issue in my musculature
and so like in early 2015 so almost two
years ago now this was shortly after
that long tour
I wouldn't got a CT scan I wouldn't got
an MRI trying to figure out like oh my
god what if I have cancer like what is
it going on and and how can I deal with
this well turns out she's I have a
really bad back and I started having
these really bad nerve problems and then
this year I this is and this is all on
top you're like what does this have to
do with your gut microbiome and chemical
sensitivities they're actually strangely
linked
and so the I started getting sciatica
earlier this year and it was the worst
pain I've ever experienced wait I'd wake
up with ten out of ten screeching panic
level pain and I've had some terrible
pain in my life and I tolerate pain
really really well I don't tolerate
discomfort very well but I tolerate pain
better than just about anyone I know and
and I was panicking in the mornings it
was that bad now I've done something
called a gas Q therapy I've been doing
yoga I've been doing stretches in fact I
do two to four hours of physical therapy
every day and it's helped me out I no
longer have the same sciatica I still
have significant back pain but I I'm
doing a lot of stuff to to help aid that
but I also am because of my chemical
sensitivities and my gut microbiome I'm
my hormones are way out of whack and so
I'm not produced what we suspect but my
team of doctors and I suspect is I'm not
producing enough human growth hormone to
be able to heal adequately and so that's
because my gut has been been so messed
up do we need to get you up HGH you joke
but but but there I mean the hormone
therapy may be something that I have to
do some time and and the not-too-distant
future and so I will tell you this Ryan
and I over the last couple years we've
signed a couple of different television
deals with with production company so
big Hollywood companies whoo-hoo we've
been setting television deals for the
details here so so so there's a
production company who has worked on
some really large television shows that
you would know the name of who
have signed a deal with us to do you
don't want to name-drop Noah and to do a
what's called a sizzle reel it's
basically the step before a pilot right
and we've done two different sizzle
reels for two different production
companies same executive producer and it
just didn't it didn't work out how we
wanted it to and so now we've had the
opportunity for a third production
company to start the process all over
again and you're like well haven't it's
uh so this whole thing we've talked
about now about why am i waiting for
these gatekeepers right and so if we
really want to we could do this thing on
our own like I don't have to because TV
is going one direction and I'm not
opposed to to the only reason I'd want
to do a TV show is if it aligns with my
values the the reason that I think
hasn't worked out very well is TV
networks want drama and we're not first
like a couple meetings we had with
production companies yes so tell me
about your events I mean you got like
people fighting in the crowds and like
yeah and now our people crying and like
the answer is yes but it's not not for
the reason it looks like it's generally
like tears of joy it's not people who
are who are you arguing with their
spouse in the crowd yes so so it's not
the same kind of drama and so we've
we've struggled with with finding the
right video video medium and that's why
we ultimately did the documentary was to
to get that out into the world that the
video side of things but how can we can
we communicate in shorter bursts and
television show seems right but now with
the internet there a bunch of other ways
that we can do that and so I'd like to
say yes to a TV show I really would and
I'd like to say yes to us doing it on
our own and we may do that at some point
but I can't say yes to that yet until I
am certain that my health is is on the
right track and I feel like it has been
on the right track I will take six steps
forward but then a few weeks ago I took
about five steps backward tumbling
backwards and started having I've had
some some kidney and liver issues
and we'll get into the details with that
but it's all it's all related to the
same the same issues that are going on
and so while I'm still gonna battling
that I will tell you that I'm very
optimistic about direction I'm going
it's just
slower going than what I would like if
it were up to me and everything was
perfectly healthy I would hit the road
right away and we'd start bringing these
six ideas out to people and instead what
we're doing it for 2017 is we're
reentering ourselves I think it's the
best thing for us to do it is you know
truly getting back to basics well yeah I
just look forward to just getting back
to I don't know I mean I don't want to
say new content but a lot more new
content it's not like I mean we've had
new content this year on the website but
I really look forward to just exploring
new ideas you know whether it comes to
environmental issues whether it comes to
the hidden costs of consumption whether
it comes to a zero zero waste folks I
mean there are there are so many things
out there that fall in alignment with
minimalism that we haven't really
touched on and that we haven't really
explored and haven't really dug into so
I really look forward into digging into
some of that stuff yeah or if we have
touched onto it we haven't really dived
headfirst into the thing and that was
the thing I liked about the documentary
it was such a great primer for a lot of
other ideas that are out there whether
it's it's minimalism or home living or
self-reliance like we have these
different ideas we want to explore I'll
tell you the thing I'm really excited
about is a improving my health on
personal note but on a professional
creative note I'm really excited to sort
of get back in the lab with you Ryan and
and really start to flesh out some ideas
together you and I have been talking the
last several months about about this
process and what excites me the most and
really that's it is getting these ideas
onto paper and then eventually working
them out in front of crowds once once
I'm healthy enough to do that so I think
the best the best time I had with you
collaborating was that first TEDx talk
we did yeah
I just remember like day one when we
were there with mihalick downstairs you
know her in our office
haha and I just remember us like
outlining it and like coming up with
ideas and stuff but like fleshing that
out over the next several months yes was
yeah that was awesome I really look
forward to getting back into that rhythm
that's exactly what I love to do and
because that impacts so many more people
than a book I mean when you think about
it so everything that remains it has
reached a lot of people and it's the
favorite thing I've done and it's a
really deep dive into a transition into
minimalism right but very few people
make it to the end of that book because
a you have to buy the book and you have
to spend you know five hours reading the
thing to get to the end and to get to
the real payoff with the TEDx talk it's
18 minutes and but you and I spend
months and months and months working on
that TEDx talk that has now reached over
two million people I just hit the two
million mark recently and so did not
know that and so it's been out there for
two or three years at this point and and
it's been able to reach far more people
and then that leads them to the podcast
or leads them to our books or to the
document I see stuff a Peter I see
people tweeting stuff at us all the time
with oh man I'm so glad I came across
your TEDx video I mean yeah it's
definitely an awesome platform yeah for
sure and so for 2017 as we get back to
basics I'm gonna continue to focus on my
health I won't have a lot of updates for
you until I make some progress because I
don't want to just say well here's where
I stand right now I want to say here's
well here's what I've learned because I
want to help you if you have any sort of
issues around that and so my chemical
sensitivities are really bad this year
we had a new office a new recording
studio set up here at the University of
Montana there's a startup incubator here
which sounds far more impressive than it
actually is but it's a pretty sweet
place yeah it's a cool building and that
we had this this room recarpet it and
refinished with with paint and we had
the furniture set up and like we were
ready to go with this brand new
beautiful recording studio that we were
setting out but I was so terribly
sensitive to the
everything in that room the paint the
carpet everything else that we had to
just we had to leave we had to strip up
the carpet and we tried to replace it
that didn't work and and and so I'm
super sensitive to chemicals I don't
have any thing that's not natural in my
house now
the the reason being is I can't I can't
handle toxins the same way other people
do your your liver should allow you to
to if you produce enough glutathione
your liver should allow you to to
process normal everyday chemicals and
and and get rid of them but my body is
basically full right now and so I'm
allergic to everything I have chemical
sensitivities I have seasonal allergies
like anything will sort of because my
glass is full it will make it overflow
and so I need to fix my gut which will
allow me to fix my hormones and allow me
to fix my glutathione production so that
long term I will have a more normal
ability to process everyday chemical so
we had to move out of that we're
actually recording this in a a
conference room right now that we have
to we set up in once a week to to record
this podcast so we'll still still be
doing that outside the move so recently
I shared a home tour Ryan you had your
home tour on on the website and I had a
our home tour with me and backs and Ella
the problem with all that home is that's
our home it's it's where we live but I
can't spend a lot of time there right
now and so I am I'm renting a small
second apartment right now to remove
myself from the the chemicals in that
house because it's a relatively new
construction it's within the last year
and I'm just sensitive to the basic
everyday off-gassing that's still going
on in that space and so how long will I
have to do that I don't know and it's
really it's a huge strain on on my
relationship with with Becca but also
with Ella I still make the best of it
and yeah it's like the the old serenity
prayer like accept the things you can't
change and then and then work hard to
change the things that you can right and
so that's what I'm doing I'm accepting
where my current stance is right now I'm
not in tip-top shape I am
the least healthy healthy person I know
I have a better diet than than anyone I
know probably I'm really really focused
and work with the team of doctors over a
nourish balanced thrive and bTW I think
we've put a link to them in the show
notes they have a great Chris has a
great podcast too I mean if you if you
have health issues he has helped over
700 people many of whom are athletes
Chris Kelly is his name Christopher
Kelly nourish balance thrive is his
practice and so I've been he haven't
worked with him and his team nurses and
doctors and food scientists to to
retrain my gut but we're getting there
and so in the meantime I'm going I'm
taking this you know one day at a time
and it's my healing process of really
working through it and I'm gonna work my
butt off to make sure that I do heal so
I can be the best version of myself for
my friends for my family for the people
that we can help on the road for our
audience in general I want to be the
best version of myself and right now I
am the best version that I can be right
now so we'll continue to give you
updates I am looking forward to getting
back to basics next year because it's
gonna give me the space I need to heal
but also I think it's important I don't
want to stop creating in fact I think
creating and getting into flow state
there's some research now that shows it
aids overall physical healing there's
some studies a lot people who are
recovering from Lyme disease which is a
horrible horrible disease to try to
recover from and and it's becoming more
and more prevalent people will recover
from Lyme disease one of the things that
helps is getting into extreme focus
states so like surfing or or writing or
bike riding things that require like
sort of full focus and full attention
it's it will help aid the healing
process especially if you have all the
other sort of gears moving in that
direction and so creating for me writing
especially it gets me into flow state
like nothing else but also I've found
that when a podcast is going really well
with you and I like the last one we did
on creating I felt like I was firing
all cylinders man I was in flow state I
felt like I was on top of the world and
so that's why I want to get back to that
and more and more creating more flow
state which will help aid the healing
will help me feel better but also not
taking on too much either and that's I'm
good at being a workaholic and so I am
constantly saying no to a lot of stuff
the only other thing that I'm saying yes
to right now and we're saying no to a
whole lot of stuff so we had a triad of
of yes so writing podcasting and maybe
doing some talks later in 2017 we'll
announce those at the website so you can
get up on our email newsletter you just
go to actually I got a new URL for if
you go to the minimalists dot email you
can sign up for our email newsletter the
minimalists email yeah it's a new domain
extension those out there now sounds
crazy yeah you can you can find that and
we'll never ever send you spam because
that's disgusting and and so yeah you
will work on a triad but then we also
have a little side project that is also
another way for us to create we're
working with some our friends from
minimally Simo and five style on a
project called minimalism dot life so
that's another extension minimalism dot
life is a website we are working on and
we're just writing some new content for
that and it's allowing me to break out
of my shell and write some different
stuff which I really like doing and it's
so gorgeous
Carl is a genius designers beautiful oh
my god I mean we moon he approached us
to start this I was flattered because he
was on his website minimally Simo was
one of the inspirations design wise for
when we were starting our blog how can I
make this as simple as what he does now
he's a beautiful photographer and
designer if if you don't if you get
anything out of this podcast just go
follow minimalism life on Instagram and
look at the photos that he's been
sharing he does these series on
minimalism life a they're just so
gorgeous it's beautiful I mean it but
it's also simple and so it's like the
bones or the beauty and so that's what
I'm gonna get back to the bare bones the
bones are the beauty and so that's we're
going to focus on in 20
it allow us to build on that in the
future whether it's doing something on
our own TV wise or allowing us to write
another book in the future or to do
larger scale tours or documentary
whatever it may be getting back to
basics will be the jump off point for
whatever we decide to do next but that's
could also mean that we're gonna be
diligent about saying no to a lot of
stuff and I said I'd finally get back to
interviews
I'm probably gonna say no to all
interviews and in 2017 unless something
big happens like I'd love to be on Joe
Rogan's podcast so if anyone's hearing
hearing this and can get us on if you
want to tweet at Joe Rogan and start
telling him that we would like to be on
his podcast that'd be awesome it's like
it's the the the one place that we
haven't been I'd love to be but we've
already kind of said everything else we
need to say in the media whether it's in
the New York Times or all the pot we've
done some great podcast interviews I
don't need to keep saying the same thing
over and over and over if it's an
opportunity to reach a whole bunch of
people then maybe we'll say yes to it
but for the most part we're gonna say no
to that so we could say yes to this new
cycle of creating and we could say yes
the interviews in the future but but we
we could say no right now so we can get
back to focusing on what's most
important right now and so I don't I
don't we we do we do other segments
usually in this podcast did you have
anything ready for an added value
segment Oh Ernie I'll talk real quick
hey check this out for those of you who
can't who don't have I don't know I am
performing karate for Josh and my new
pants that I just bought aha
so I usually I get the same I usually
get the same pair of jeans every single
time but they were out uh-huh
so I tried out these new pair they're
called barbell Marshall actually I'm
sure like there's a lot of people out
there who are very aware of this jean
company uh-huh but like I'm just now
finding them out and yeah long story
short they are the most comfortable pair
of jeans I've ever put on
Wow they're freaking awesome wow that is
great I listen to two albums that just
came out recently
one is Jay Cole's new album called for
your eyes only
it's drums what that drug is so good
that I can't wait it's so good but then
also our friend dude as soon as we get
out our friend Jay Nash he put out an
all acoustic album called Vermont
sessions nice it's probably my favorite
thing he's ever done he's still a minute
Vermont I love ya we have I know
well he's invited us to go stay at his
cabin he played a few songs for us when
we did a Boston tour stop in 2014 he's
just one of my favorite musicians I
think he's one of the best songwriters
alive and we connected via Twitter and
we've become friends in the last three
years or so he's actually when his songs
Wayfarer is in the fifth chapter of
everything that remains so everything
that remains is the only book I know of
that has a soundtrack every every
chapter has a song in it although I
guess you we could like sort of Spotify
playlist or something but I'd haven't
done that yet it's a good idea but yeah
so everything that remains has a
soundtrack and he is in that book and he
happened to read the book and loved it
and I'm like oh my god my songs in there
and so he did this acoustic album it's
unbelievable it's so good so we'll put a
link to both of those in the show notes
and and we'll throw a link to Ryan do
him karate in the show notes as well
these may be the jeans that he's wearing
dude I'm telling you man like like I
just cannot say it any other way like I
wish I could produce more words right
now to express you how freaking
comfortable these jeans are men but they
they're just like by far the best pair
of pants I've ever put on that's
beautiful
all right Ryan so you know we usually do
this hashtag ask the minimalist
lightening round but we didn't have one
prepared before him but I sent out a
tweet and I got a few questions the
tweet just said we're gonna record a
podcast episode about the New Year New
Directions and getting back to basics
what would you like to hashtag asked of
the minimalists and we got a few
questions here let's just riff on these
real quick go for it if you don't mind
Jamie says how do you start working
toward a goal
and ensuring you remain accountable to
achieving that goal I'll start off just
by saying you know I don't I don't have
goals anymore and I've written about
this and I know this sounds like
semantics but really I prefer to have a
direction over a goal and so we wrote an
essay we'll put it in the show notes
it's from where our book essential and
there's a link to it on our website as
well so I prefer to have a direction
over a goal and in fact I wrote an essay
about living a hundred days without
goals and so we can use we can put that
link in the show notes as well and that
was a very eye-opening experience but if
you do want to if you're gonna put goals
out there I would encourage you to have
fewer goals right because the more goals
you have the more you will stress
yourself out that was really the point
of that experiment if you want to remain
accountable then get an accountability
partner have external accountability and
I think that's important I work with
Ryan and Shawn and they both help keep
keeping me accountable and I'm grateful
for that it makes me a better person
I'll try to hold myself accountable but
I also have people around me who will
hold me accountable - yeah how do you
start towards that goal that's an
interesting question like I'm thinking
about like maybe someone who has you
know six figures worth of debt like I
have a lot of mentoring clients who they
went through school eight years later
they've got six figures worth of debt
and they got decent jobs and they could
pay all that debt down you know if they
stopped spending so much but it's hard
because like you know you work 40 50 60
hours a week and you don't want to come
home and eat peanut butter and jelly
like it's you want yeah you want it now
alright right yeah it's justification
much yeah instant gratification much
easier said than done to just be like
well just start eating peanut butter and
jelly for every meal until your debts
paid off and right yeah so what I would
say like in those cases for example
where I'll just use that example or
someone has six figures worth of debt
and they are not maybe spending beyond
their means but they're not paying off
their debt as fast as they would like to
let's say that they initiate they want
to initiate spending less what I would
suggest to them is like a budget first
off the like shoes do that likes once
versus needs homeless that we talk about
which you can find out the
minimalist calm / one yeah that's a good
one of my favorite I says I'd explain
this but these are supposed to be pithy
answers aren't they for the lightning
round but but really ultimately getting
started
I think entails being motivated and one
thing that really helps me get motivated
when I am trying to incorporate new
habits into my life or if I'm trying to
reach a certain goal or start a new
direction I will write down all the
reasons why I want to start that new
goal or why I went ahead in that
direction and get really clear on why I
want a certain outcome and the reason
why writing these down it's not a matter
of okay well yeah there it is here the
six reasons why and I'm gonna think
about these writing it down is much more
powerful and here's why when you go to
that what not you but you know the
person who's trying to spend less when
they go to the store and they want to
buy that big flame you know big piece of
filet mignon that costs however much
they could pull that list out and they
can read all those reasons why and
that's a way to help hold people
accountable yes because it's like you
have to look at yourself in the mirror
and say you know what yeah here's all
the reasons why I don't want to do this
and I'm going to go ahead and ignore all
that and I'm gonna go and buy this piece
of steak it's a lot harder to say no to
yourself when you're reminding yourself
right there and making yourself look in
the mirror as to why you are
incorporating this habit in the first
place but either way getting started is
by far I think the hardest part yeah
yeah well and I was listening to Jaco
willings podcast recently I don't know
if you've ever heard of Jack or well Inc
he's a former Navy SEAL and someone
asked him like how do I take the first
step toward bravery and he gives these
really pithy answers on Twitter he just
responded step and that's really like
what's what's the first step toward a
goal step take step you gotta take that
step and because the first few steps are
the most difficult because you don't
have any momentum and you need that
inertia to take you forward continually
so but you need the leverage as well so
what you talked about is the writing
those things down that's giving you the
leverage you need to stay motivated for
the
because once you do step you have to
keep stepping and does it get easier but
you want that leverage and so maybe the
question to put on that list there with
the the all the reasons why is before
you're about to make that decision
you're about to buy that widget or
whatever
ask yourself with the best version of
myself a make this decision yeah that's
a great way to look at it and I think if
you ask it that way you'll you'll help
identify no this isn't the best version
of me yeah that's a great that's a great
way of looking at it because ultimately
what is that to man it changes our
emotion right like you ask yourself it
would the best version of myself do this
it makes you feel something and like
that is that's really what we operate
off of with all our decisions man is are
we running towards pleasure are we
running away from pain so the more you
can associate with doing that habit
associated with pleasure and not doing
it associated with pain then yeah you're
more likely to follow through with that
habit so is what the best version of
myself by this widget if the answer is
no and then you buy it well I mean
that's gonna make you feel pretty crappy
right right totally agree hey what's
next April says how do you measure
success throughout the year well we have
we've got 26 different categories that
we're constantly keeping up with how
many likes do we get on Twitter how many
Twitter followers we did we gained this
year yeah what are our success metrics
you know and it's funny because a lot of
people do look at it that way I look at
our traffic on our website once a year
just to see how many people visited our
website in the last year and the same
goes with this podcast I haven't looked
in a long time last time Shawn tallied
up everything it was it was over
three-quarters of a million people
listening in all the different formats
but that that is impressive in one sense
but it's not really when you think about
it because just because let's say
million people watch you know a TED talk
it doesn't mean a million people got the
same amount of value from from that
thing and so the question is how are you
actually going to define
your success that's how you're gonna
measure the success is you have to
figure out the best way to define it so
what does success look like for you I'll
tell you what it looks like for me do my
short-term actions
align with my long term values that is
success that's going to equal
contentment that's going to equal
happiness not ephemeral pleasure but but
lasting happiness and it's also going to
keep me moving in the right direction
because my values tend not to change my
beliefs change in time and that that's
okay that that will change my path a
little bit or sometimes a lot but it'll
still give me the same value so do my
short term actions align with my values
and my beliefs or the path to get to
those values and so that's how you're
going to figure out how you're
successful throughout the year and it
rarely has anything to do with the
things we can measure with a a
calculator sometimes it might sometimes
it might make sense you've got to have
enough money to pay the bills right or
if you're trying to get out of debt I
know that's a big thing for the new year
a lot of people making resolutions to
lose weight or get out of debt well if
you want to get out of debt go back and
listen to our debt podcast we do whole
episode on it but also read our our
financial freedom essay we wrote about
exactly there the five steps that Ryan
and I took in fact it's called the five
difficult stuff to get out of debt
because it was not easy it was fairly
simple but it was difficult so we simple
ain't easy no simple can be difficult
but it is the simplest route and and so
it was what we did to get out of debt
and now we are debt free and you better
believe I'm gonna stay deaf for you'll
never be getting back into debt any time
and the rest of my life
yeah I would totally echo he said short
term values along with long term value
or short term actions aligning with long
term values and beliefs I mean
ultimately that to me means living a
meaningful life and like that is what
success means to me if I feel like I'm
living a meaningful life than I I am
successful I'd certainly had different
measures of success you know of my
corporate days of yesteryear but uh but
now I mean that's pretty much what it
comes down to it's like do I have good
people in my life do I have good health
am i able to you know kind of pursue
some of these hobbies that I have a my
growing am i contributing like that's
that's success
yeah so ask yourself what what is
success what does it look like for you
and then get specific with it well what
what how do i define my value is what
are my beliefs what are my interest and
then how do i line my actions with those
with those values and I think you'll
find thats how you're gonna define
success much more than a paycheck or a
number of Instagram followers last
question here a lot of these are pretty
similar about noise and and new year's
goals and stuff which we just kind of
covered but Neal he says how do I get
back to basics
emotionally 2016 has been nuts globally
and personally how do i how do i
simplify the emotional clutter I'll just
say first off go back and once to our
podcast called noise I think that's a
great way to get started we did a whole
podcast on quieting the noise but
remember you're in charge of most of the
inputs that affect your life and yes
you're gonna see 5,000 advertisements a
day but you can at least turn down the
dimmer switch of advertisements you can
put up ad blockers yeah if you stop
watching TV if you yeah there's plenty
of ways just to turn down that noise
but I'd only think I think I would add
to that is any stone you've picked up
you can set it down yes any stone you
picked up that you've responsibility
you've put on yourself you also have the
ability to take it off your shoulders
and set it down and keep walking yes yes
I think that's beautiful I think it's a
great place to end that we'll move on
real quick to right here right now so
where we talk about I don't have a
script in front of me so Ryan we talked
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalist that's us and so Ryan and
I are traveling a little bit we've been
doing some fun tours we call the
minimalists city fines so if you go to
our Instagram page you don't even have
to be on Instagram to check this out you
can just go to Instagram comm slash the
minimalists we will share some of our
favorite experiences whether it's
Christmas tree hunting or cryotherapy or
going to a concert or just a really cool
breakfast spot in LA we're going to be
going to Florida soon we're gonna see a
concert there Griffin House is is
performing and
we're just gonna be hanging out at the
coffee shop our coffee shop and that
Coffee Co we're doing some remodeling
there and we're gonna share a little bit
of that on on instagram using the
hashtag the minimalists city fund so
this is a great point B for those who
are listening to this right now because
all those events you just talked about
would have already happened
yes but they can google hashtag or then
just go to our Instagram page and click
on and then they can see all of our they
could see all of our minimalist City
funds yes all of our antics and all the
good times we're having all the
experiences we have in a different City
so if you go to that City whether it's
Dayton Ohio or Los Angeles or Spokane or
a bunch of other cities we've gotten to
you can you know maybe share one or two
of those experiences as well all right
we probably want to play some voicemails
now we I'm sure Shawn can queue up some
voicemails we have some some listener
tips and tricks about minimalism and
wait that's my line usually alright go
ahead now here are some tips and tricks
from our listeners I don't think that's
the line is it tricks and tips I don't
know go ahead and play a shot hi Josh
and Ryan I actually just wanted to call
you and rather than a question or a
comment to share with you a bit of my
own successfully like you I grew up in
less than ideal circumstances to say
that I grew up in volatile conditions is
an understatement my parents once pulled
me out of middle school class to let me
know that my siblings and I needed to
say goodbye to our friends that day at
school because that evening we needed to
talk about all of our belongings and
move across state so early on I was
conditioned to pack light and be
prepared to leave all of my possessions
and relationships in a moment's notice
that that specific time we moved across
state to a campground in which we live
for three years in a tent and then also
in like a pop-up camper while my dad was
serving consecutive sentences for
multiple DUIs endangerment and
possession charges all of our
possessions were in storage unit which
we ultimately lost to auction
because my parents could no longer
afford to pay to storagee at rent so it
became an unspoken rule that we carry
with us the possessions that we could
pack up in a day's notice because of how
often you're addicted and how often we
needed to you know be prepared to be on
the go
so when I was 14 I started working
part-time to save money to move out of
my parents house to find security and a
cushy career and I have one now and I
also wanted to prove to myself that I
could stand on my own two feet which I
have but I spent the majority of my
adult life collecting possessions than I
previously did not have the ability to
either afford or a team so by the time I
discovered your podcast just last year
at the age of 31 I was depressed I was
recently divorced
I was rifled and stressed by my things
and your podcast really helped me pull
out of that depression and provided you
with the inspiration I needed to free
myself up from that material value I
just wanted to let you know that because
of your ability to share your story
today I'm happy I'm 30 pounds later I'm
experiencing life rather than collecting
things hi Josh and Ryan just a few tips
about your listeners and also things
I've learned on the way let your kids
wear heirloom jewelry and play dress-up
have a tea party or a candlelight dinner
you'll make memories and bring meaning
by doing so you can frame the jewelry in
a shadowbox and display it as art IKEA
is a great resource
they're nice way to edit collections or
honor the memory of a loved one by
framing their mementos and pictures in a
small contained space I found useful
sentimental items brought me the most
meaning I cook with my mom's wooden
spoon daily and warn my kids with the
Afghan my grandma knitted I'm finally
donating the China I've kept in a box
for 20 plus years because I realized it
won't have any meaning or relevance for
my daughter since I never used it
replacements comm is resource to sell
china and silverware for everyday
practical items by quality and
aesthetically pleasing once by the
flowery nail clippers if people won't
stop giving you things swing by goodwill
on your way home and get a receipt treat
it like candy
don't even bring it into your house find
resources online for recycling pay for
postage if it means that much but give
yourself permission to toss these items
those items that won't be donated while
you're establishing a baseline you'll be
causing much less in the future wean off
shopping by going to thrift stores and
yard sales always have a list of needs
remember a dollar spent is still a
dollar spent and even free might come
with a price I've been known to replace
all the items in my cart back to their
respective places treating each as if
the hunch was satisfying enough and
feeling empowered by asking the hard
questions and making the conscious
choice not to possess it take a picture
if you want to remember it take pictures
of your kids art and make a book turn
old t-shirts into quilts or pillows for
everyone excuse me one new thing rid
yourself of two things - libraries are
cropping up for borrowing tools if you
don't have one start one volunteer at
hands-on Network org register click to
sign up and then show up when we lost
our business and house and filed
bankruptcy we volunteered when my
husband died in an accident three years
later we volunteered don't underestimate
the power of giving to and doing for
others for me passion equals pressure
instead I'm following my curiosities and
my love of learning if that leads to a
passion then that's great and if not
that's okay too because I will have
learned a lot along the way
thank you for spreading the message in
defining and affirming what I've been
working on for years I really appreciate
what you're both doing alright that's it
for this episode folks if you have a
question for the minimalist let's see if
I remember the phone number without a
script Ryan it's 406 to 1 9 7 8 3 9 if
you do call us and leave a question or a
tip make sure you you write down your
your question or tip beforehand it'll
help you be more articulate and it will
greatly increase your chances of
reaching the airwaves are these airwaves
now I don't even know let's just let's
just sign off and yeah if you leave here
with one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'll be
fighting without
[Music]
every little thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you gotta grab oh I bet
that you'll be fine without me
so tear your eyes or tea
[Music]
he
you
[Music]